lot of players now are playing the
Queen's Gambit decline line and it
normally starts with a move like E6 this
is kind of the most common to move at
top level play and what it does is
if white tries to take on D5 black can
simply come back
and he's got great Center control he's
holding down this E4 Square white can't
come to the center
and he's building up a great defense the
one weakness that he has though is he is
closed in his Bishop from moving and as
far as opening Theory you never want to
close in your Bishops with your pawns
and in any opening you should always
keep notice to that especially for
yourself and your opponents